hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play a machine
for pigs I've been playing this AI in 20
minute bursts and after each one I have
to go lay down in the light because holy
balls
this game is unbelievable I hate it so
much changers like this this job to
collect so close to the core we can use
the flow to drive the turbines granted
it'd always be a torrent of excretes I'm
flooding through these terms you use
this to supplement the steam production
and ensure constant served a god this
stench this fecal matter is the truth
product of the age right so you're gonna
use the power of sewage to power your
machines so fitting naturally once bled
the product must be scalded D hair
scraped and ready for gambling and
evisceration but this we pass them
through the steam reservoir which is
kept at a constant temperature bypassing
excess I pressure venting from the
engines via the boiler in series of
large copper pipes into a stone chamber
just below the workhouse at the center
of the gene there's a compound that must
be kept at a consistently low
temperature which controls operations
the processing of the product throughout
the system alongside this refrigeration
is well the utmost important in
retaining product quality and this also
requires heat to be removed from certain
areas and machine do problems are
therefore combined into a single
solution removal of the heat from some
eras and requirement for increased
heating the others conducting patents
draw heat from the using principle of
convection regulated by the boiler
setting them freezing air along set of
pipes in one direction and superheated
vapors in another Wow a lot of
mumbo-jumbo on how to use your [ __ ] to
power oh no no no no no no no no oh no
no no oh no not oh no no oh no oh no no
no no God no ho-oh I had a bad feeling
oh [ __ ] you
oh [ __ ] you so I'm not even looking I
don't care I'll [ __ ] you you're a shitty
shitty water monster [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
God there's just [ __ ] everywhere why am
i down here why I can practically smell
it okay
is that actually a thingy that sounds
like a thingy little piggy no no little
piggy go home little piggy little piggy
little piggy you ain't gonna get me he
sounds pretty close but where is he he
sounds like he's this way so let's go
find him let's go runs back anyone who
hi hey piggy piggy piggy okay bye bye
bye bye now bye bye forever
I hate sewers
I hate screw you I see a valve over
there I know I'm gonna have to turn it
screwed oh I'm in the water home in the
water
oh hello piggy piggy oh I do not want to
go I do not want to go
kachunk
ask fine who's we
several the older forms have reached
their containment area and escaped into
the sewers they remind me of my
limitations
this is no Kelman I am no Leu at least
not quite yet it is the heat generated
from keeping the doorway between open
that is to blame we cannot simply pack
them about with coolant as we do the
entire at the center where the doorway
is the later versions are kept safe by
the freezing temperatures of these
towers up here where the air is hot and
fetid they become overheated and their
duality tears them asunder as the other
place flies from their cells and their
vit a splinters they live sporadically
torn from one world to the other and
back again then violent unpredictable
bursts for a few seconds they're
creatures of this world then they are
torn away in seeks to have physical form
this vicious tripping back and forth
between the worlds has driven them quite
insane I have ordered the affected areas
sealed and will not allow my loyal
workers to enter these are play these
are damned places now and abide of
failed experiments ghosts and fear and
spite ghosts of fear and spite ok but
either way I think you're talking about
the water monsters that are kind of all
angry and whatnot
okay
nope nope nope nope nope not doing that
I'm not doing it
[ __ ] that screw that I'm not doing it
nope nope there's got to be another way
right there's got to be another way I
mean what the hell am I supposed to do
he's right there I'm not gonna be able
to how did I even get here wasn't there
another there we go okay I'm gonna go
this way gonna go this way
you guys are gonna go screw yourselves
understand you get this get my message
no no no God please no no no oh whatever
is there another way I think I seem to
be in a slightly different area right oh
hi
hey buddy how's duh how you doing you're
lookin good
you're lookin good you've been working
out good good fantastic good to see you
good to see you stop jumping at me I'm
not I'm not having it
I'm not having any of it okay I'm just
not having it you go screw yourself and
die that's what I want I want you to go
to hell and die
god damnit up back at the beginning
again ferns I thought I went to a
different place but I'm exactly where I
left off before crap oh this is open now
oh thank goodness oh oh it's open oh
this is open okay we're gonna be fine
we're gonna have happy fun times over
here it's gonna be great and we're all
gonna have sunshine and ice cream that's
okay all right then let's open this
valve BAM sluice to open and good ready
for business give me that give it that
and I said look my darlings can you see
it they said yes Daddy yes we see it at
all weathered cap of steel sided pyramid
like those of Egypt stone falling away
from the summit vines crawling about the
intertwining of stucco serpents that
thrive about their steps a palpable
sense of stillness await forgotten and
this here this is where the King sat and
this is where the priests lived this
house this is the house of the dead and
here where the Sun strikes this is where
they threw the hearts that were not
consumed no my darling they most
certainly we're not savages you see they
believed that the sky could fall on
their heads and they truly truly
believed that offering blood was the
only way of stopping this from happening
perhaps my darling perhaps they were
mistaken altogether or perhaps their
tragedy was they could not simply not
spill blood enough to prevent the sky
from falling in upon them yeah that's
what happened yeah I'm sure that's
totally correct Yeah right wait a minute
this was open okay never mind I know
that I opened sploit to see what no did
I get lots of reading that's done it now
I can enter the strange decontamination
chamber once again wall does a push back
making the bilge clear then back into
Thames where it belongs okay whatever
you're supposed to [ __ ] whatever Khurana
oh you I almost shut up I almost walked
right into that I don't want to hear any
of it
Claire Clank open up I can't believe I
almost walked right into that guy I knew
it couldn't be like that knew it
couldn't be
Bing
I'll need to be really decontaminated
more than this after I've been wallowing
around in this freakin sewer Bing come
on and I'm right back into the sewer fan
okay all righty then
hi buddy how you doing that's to you how
you doing down there
one's bigger than the other one is
waving oh but geez man why he gotta be
like that he was just walking along
minding his own bit all he's hurt now oh
the poor little I don't give a [ __ ] okay
so anyway Wow
what the hell oh my god
what the hell that is messed up man whoa
that is messed up okay dear God a whole
nest of these foul creatures no mind my
instincts have drawn me thus far and I'm
sure somewhere in this dank complex as a
means of further descent I will not see
their faces as they go about their dark
business and yet and yet I watched them
sleep and eat and play and they are so
very human so very childlike and I will
not think of what I have seen of the
chairs in the cages and I will not think
of how such monsters may be sculpted it
because you made them all right
it's almost nice music that's going on
what was it oh yeah the music was meant
to soothe the creatures that's correct I
remember that now what was that what
just happened
oh hi hey are you playing oh you're
playing with blocks that's crazy
creepy and extremely disturbing are all
these - all these have portholes that I
can open do any of them do okay it was
just that one okay anyway there's a
doorway through here that is that is
very strange just being honest here I
really like that they've totally removed
all semblance of an inventory it's all
based down to just what is interactable
in the environment that helps with
immersion immensely ooh
you slipped and fell sorry about that
sorry to make you do that were you
excited to see your master okay sorry
you have to live like this not sorry
okay I'm literally in with them this is
so weird
it's so weird hey buddy you're sleeping
sleeping buddy take a little nap little
catnap little big nap big nap
sleepy piggy are you crying down there I
don't blame you holy crap this is so
messed up coming out of here get me out
of it it's so weird it's so weird oh I
hear them right behind me when I'm
walking away okay god that's so weird
that was so weird okay all right
still normal oh my god no my god
you're the worst thing about playing
this is it's a totally new amnesia so
all of my prior experience goes out the
window I actually have no idea what to
expect half of the time oh my god oh man
I just love all the changes that they
made the no oil mix is so much better
because they don't even have to worry
about that and that means that they can
change on my light they can change the
scenario based on the understanding that
I'm always gonna have a light source
that they can use and or take away from
me when necessary and it means that I'm
not hunting around for oil or worrying
about that or tinder boxes or anything
like that I mean I kind of miss the
sanity being gone though
I mean the sanity was one of the coolest
things about amnesia but I can see how
it could get annoying it did get
annoying sometimes and it did seem like
it wasn't really doing all that much now
that I think about it so maybe it's for
the best
just streamline the experience what is
that it's a big verbal glowing door
leads to what I wonder what devilish
creatures lie within from tide to spine
and who is that third that shadow that
spirit child in the background that
barely formed that changeling that
almost lived that never missed okay all
right you seem to have undergone quite a
profound conversion in Mexico mr. Miller
job would not have seen it yourself and
not professor as we disembark even
through my fever
I saw the detritus of this so-called
progress I sought starvation and disease
rot and destruction polluting the waters
of the Empire
we are ruinous you and I and all of us
and we make the world unclean and you
took it upon yourself to act as Redeemer
professor I would not be so sure
Amelia cool I am constructing an
architecture to wrestle our damnation to
the ground and smother it with steam
whose hair me well this so-called
saboteur you go on so much about yeah
you told me to wait what do you mean by
that these must be the bilge pumps I am
at the heart of the saboteurs efforts in
order to keep his flood in place he must
have disabled these vast pumps but he
was clearly rushed thus far he has left
most of his work incomplete his clumsy
efforts reduced to simply switching off
all he could find if I can locate the
retool the controls the remedies should
be simple if you say so
ah come on I didn't even notice I'm
surrounded alrighty then hi friend go F
yourself
I had the trickle to still waters I
dragged myself deep into the temple
down
towards a win that helped the voices of
my children
beckoning me to set them free
oh I didn't even notice that till it
exploded into blood righty-ho yeah
you're not going maybe I'm not dealing
with insanity because this guy is
already crazy I feel crazy for playing
this game I feel crazy for being here
I feel crazy for doing this oh hi why
are you all lecture key is that the side
effect of you being ripped in between
worlds hi I have a feeling I'm gonna
visit you who did I just a showdown like
what did I just say I didn't even
register it didn't even register till
after it was never mind you know what
never mind
I don't want to hear any of it everybody
pause and tell me what the Frick and
frack that was hello mr. pig mask if
that - you really are out - light bulb
never mind
light bulb uh uh uh nope nope nope
it got really quiet all of a sudden
wonder why that is
wait a minute this doesn't help me Oh am
I supposed to climb along the pipes
maybe maybe not no probably not that
seems like a very stupid idea how about
we turn this valve instead of jumping on
top of pipes how about we do that
okay
ah I knew it I knew it I freaking knew
it oh man I knew it I'm not exactly sure
why I'm happy that I knew that but
whatever I still knew it
okay now where am I going and when am I
gonna be thrown into the water I know
it's gonna happen eventually just when
when another pump it seems once again I
must engage it I cannot heal help but
feel I am trapped in some great game
forced to undertake endless Herculean
Labor's for the promised reward of my
darling children well hate to tell you
this but you actually are in a game one
of the worst most horrific games ever
made
now one of the best most horrific games
ever made
oh no no no oh no oh no oh no oh no no
no no no I'm good ooh I got a baguette
damn gotta get it that stack it's so
much worse when there's no music
I knew it was gonna happen I knew it was
gonna drop me in at some point I knew it
I knew it had to is it oh wait no hey
look at that it's the other side of
where I fell well that's good
where did that come from I don't even
know did that come from this way or what
so confused so confused
where am i is that where I am I'm pretty
low in this freaking machine man okay
hi anyway I'm a last time for this part
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
no no there you go fire the cannon fire
huh good yeah now go down
oh god damn it
dummy out of me okay I'm an idiot why
did that scare me I have no idea and
just saw a big shadowy figure I saw a
shadow I